what i want to do in this video is
discuss a special class of triangles
called 30 60 90 triangles and i think
you know why they're called this the
measures of its angles are 30 degrees 60
degrees and 90 degrees and what we're
going to prove in this video this tends
to be a very useful result at least for
a lot of what you see in a geometry
class and then later on in trigonometry
class is the ratios between the sides of
a 30-60-90 triangle that if the
hypotenuse has the length x
so that's remember the hypotenuse is
opposite the 90 degree side if the
hypotenuse has length x what we're going
to prove is that the shortest side which
is opposite the 30 degree side has
length x over 2
and that the 60 degree side
the 60 degree side or the side that's
opposite the 60 degree angle i should
say is going to be square root of 3
times the shortest side so square root
of 3 times x over 2. that's going to be
its length so that's what we're going to
prove in this video in other videos
we're going to apply this we're going to
show this is actually a pretty useful
result now let's start with a triangle
that we're very familiar with so let me
draw ourselves an equilateral triangle
so
drawing the triangles is always the hard
part so this is my best shot at an
equilateral triangle and let's call
so let's call this
a
b
c i'm just going to assume that i've
constructed an equilateral triangle so
triangle a
b c
is equilateral and if it's equilateral
that that means all of its sides are
equal and let's say that it has length
and let's say equilateral with
sides
of length
of length x
so this is going to be x this is going
to be x and this is going to be x we
also know based on what we've seen from
equilateral triangles before that all
the measures of all of these angles are
going to be 60 degrees so this is going
to be 60 degrees this is going to be 60
degrees and then this is going to be 60
degrees now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to drop an altitude from this top
point right over here so i'm going to
drop an altitude right down and by
definition when i'm constructing an
altitude it's going to intersect the
base right here at a right angle so
that's going to be a right angle and
then this is going to be a right angle
and it's a pretty straightforward proof
to show that this is not only not only
is this an altitude not only is it
perpendicular to this base but it's a
pretty straightforward proof to show
that it bisects the base and you could
pause it if you like and prove it
yourself but it really comes out of the
fact that it's easy to prove that these
two triangles are congruent so let me
prove it for you so let's call this
point d right over here so triangles a b
d and b d c they clearly both share this
side so this side is common to both of
them right over here and then we could
do whatever that we have they this angle
right over here is congruent to this
angle over there this angle right over
here is congruent to this angle over
here and so if these two are congruent
to each other then the third angle has
to be congruent to each other so this
angle right over here needs to be
congruent to that angle right over there
so these two are congruent and so you
can use actually a variety of our of our
congruence postulates we could say side
angle side side angle side congruence we
could use we could use angle side angle
any of those to show that triangle
triangle a
b d
is congruent is congruent to triangle c
c
b d
and what that does for us and we could
use as i said we could use angle side
angle or side angle side whatever we
like to use for this what that does for
us is it tells us that the corresponding
sides of these triangles are going to be
equal in particular in particular the
length of
in particular a d is going to be equal
to c d
a d is going to be equal to c d these
are corresponding sides so these are
going to be equal to each other and if
we know that they're equal to each other
and they add up to x remember this was
an equilateral triangle of length x we
know that this side right over here is
going to be x over 2. we know this is
going to be x over 2. not only do we
know that but we also knew when we when
we dropped this altitude we showed that
this angle has to be congruent to that
angle and their measures have to add up
to 60. so if two things are the same
they add up to 60 this is going to be at
30 degrees and this is going to be 30
degrees so we've already shown one of
the interesting parts of a 30-60-90
triangle that if the hypotenuse notice
and i guess i didn't point this out by
dropping this altitude i've essentially
split this equilateral triangle into two
30-60-90 triangles 30 60 90 triangles
and so we've already shown that if the
side opposite the 90 degree side is x
that the side opposite the 30 degree
side is going to be x over 2. that's
what we showed right over here now we
just have to come up with the third side
the side that is opposite the 60 degree
side
right over there and let's call that at
let's call that length let's call i'll
just use i'll just use the letters that
we already have here this is bd and we
can just use the pythagorean theorem
right here bd squared plus this length
right over here squared plus x over 2
squared is going to be equal to the
hypotenuse squared so we get b d
b d
squared plus x over 2 squared this is
just straight out of the pythagorean
theorem plus x over 2 squared is going
to equal this hypotenuse squared is
going to equal x squared and just to be
clear i'm looking at this triangle right
here i'm looking at this triangle right
over here on the right and i'm just
applying the pythagorean theorem this
side squared plus this side squared is
going to equal the hypotenuse squared
and let's solve now for bd you get b
d squared plus
x squared over 4
x squared over 4 is equal to x squared
is equal to x squared you could view
this as 4x squared over 4. that's the
same thing obviously as x squared and
then if we subtract if you subtract 1 if
you subtract 1 4 x squared from both
sides or x squared over 4 from both
sides you get b d squared is equal to
4 x squared over 4 minus x squared over
4 is going to be 3x squared over 4. so
it's going to be 3 x squared over 4 take
the principal root of both sides you get
bd
is equal to
is equal to the square root of 3
times x
principle root of 3 is square root of 3
principle of x squared is just x over
the principal root of 4 which is 2. and
bd is the side opposite the 60 degree
side so we're done if this hypotenuse is
x the side opposite the 30 degree side
is going to be x over 2 and the side
opposite the 60 degree side is going to
be square root of 3 over 2 times x or
square root of 3 x over 2 depending on
how you want to view it